counselor phil shaw can you please
are we live streaming sonia
yeah thank you good morning my name is
councillor shaw and i am the chairman of
the license and appeals subcommittee for
today's hearing
my fellow fellow committee members are
councillor carol weston
councillor phil shaw and our sub member
is councillor mike lucas gill
the committee clerk is sonya worthington
and the
principal democratic corporate services
officer is rebecca hurst and my screen's
frozen rebecca
can't read it
sorry um the legal advisor rebecca
please bear with me my friend screen has
just completely frozen but we will
continue this when i can read it off my
phone the legal adviser is rebecca her
senior solicitor
the purpose of the hearing is to
consider an application for a review of
premises
relating a premises license relating to
the premises known as crafty cup
crop casks 33 eastwood wrote
rayleigh please can everyone use their
microphones when speaking and mute them
when they are not required to speak
please also ensure that you follow the
council procedure
on remote meetings you will have an
opportunity to speak and ask questions
please only speak when it is your turn
please can a council office before i do
that i would like to make a statement
regarding this this is a formal meeting
and it will be live streamed and we i
will not want
appropriate behavior and language use
within this meeting please
can the license hold can they
council's officer please introduce
himself
i'm stephen greenough i'm the principal
licensing
thank you could the applicant introduce
himself
do you propose to call any witnesses
good morning chairman uh councillor mike
wilkinson i'm the award counselor for
weekly warden which is premises situated
and yes i do propose to call
a witness who's a resident in the
residential block immediately above
the premises in discussion today thank
you
councillor wilkinson could the license
hold holder introducing himself
and do you propose to call any witnesses
yes i'm uh john smith the license holder
and i'd like to call
ellie smith as a witness please
thank you thank you very much could the
council's environmental health officer
introduce herself do you propose to call
any witnesses uh good morning my name's
siobhan and
i'm not intending to call any witnesses
also
today present is my colleagues james
[ __ ] and andrew padden
thank you very much but the introduced
interested
parties introduce themselves
hello again my name is ellie smith and i
live directly above crafty cast at 31c
eastwood road thank you very much
hi i'm larissa ian and i'm one of the
residents of alphacorp
i also live above crafty cars on the
road
thank you very much have all the
the parties received agenda and report
for today's hearing
thumbs up for everyone you've got no one
saying no so that looks like that's a
good one thank you
um the committee at the last meeting
agreed
and it's gone again all my screens are
freezing i'm afraid
the committee at the last meeting
agreed to view the cctv at the
conclusion of the
case without commentary we the community
committee agree with that decision
um we have spoken to the new members of
the committee and is still stands
as the footage contains images of
members of the public
this part of the hearing will be will
not be uh streamed to avoid potential
breaches
of the gdpr
the order of the parties to make those
submissions
will be as follows licensing officer mr
greener
applicant councillor wilkinson
responsible authority that being
environmental health miss sheridan
interested parties and then the license
holder mr smith
the time limit of 15 minutes per party
remains in place
15 minutes is the total time of all
interested parties and will be
apportioned between them
freeze if all parties could amend their
copy of the procedure as follows
right now
counseling council's license officer
will be asked to introduce the
application
and present their reports the ice
license officer will not normally go
through the report in full as is
anticipated that the subcommittee and
the parties have read it
the subcommittee and the parties may
seek clarification from the licensing
officers on mata's race in reports so
it will be um steve green in first
please
this morning as it's already been stated
i won't be going through the full report
um but i will be like paragraphs
within the report and for the assistance
of the parties that are participating in
this hearing
it is an application for a review of a
license under section 61
based on the licensing objectives and
the review was submitted on the 28th
of august 2020 in relation to crafty
tasks
within page 4.9 of the documentation
that has been circulated
councillor wilkinson has requested that
this license
is either removed
or completely overhauled with additional
conditions and vastly restricted
hours of business
4.13 of the documentation is a copy of
the premises license
and you will see that the premises
license only has the sale of alcohol
within the actual license however there
is going to be conversations around
other aspects of licensable activity
which relates to regulated entertainment
this falls under section 177 of the live
music deregulation
and it stipulates if a premises has an
alcohol license
then they are allowed to have the live
music deregulation
of live or recorded music up to 11
o'clock at night
and therefore is not necessarily
recorded on the premises
license but as i said it will be
mentioned and will be discussed today
going back to the report paragraph 4.2
stipulates that essex police have not
made any
representation in support of the review
and also paragraph 4.3 of the report the
licensing authority have not made any
representation either
on 4.24 of the documentation
environmental health have made
representation
however they have proposed conditions
um to try and address the issues
and these are also under page 4.25
unfortunately the venue and
environmental health have not been able
to agree
a way forward however the venue have
offered conditions under page 4.86
and 4.88 of their proposed
conditions that they would be offering
to be attached to the license
other interested parties have also
submitted letters
and they can be found on page 4.68
and to 4.82 and we have
a couple of people present with us that
have actually included
their representation that they will be
verbally updating within this hearing
under the licensing policy which is
issued
which is a five-year policy on
paragraphs 5.7
it mentions
that the applicants may wish to consider
the following examples of control
measures that
might be included in their operating
schedule where appropriate how regards
to particular
type of premises and there's a number of
measures that are actually within
our policy of measures that could be
considered in relation
to control measures including noise
limiters
adoption of soundproofing air
conditioning
there's a number of different measures
including as well management of people
including staff
traffic and people arriving and leaving
the premises
in addition to this on page 19
and in paragraph 1.8
of the policy it says an application for
a review
will only be relevant if the grounds
upon which
it is made relate to the promotion of at
least
one of the four licensing objectives and
is
not victorious or repetitive any
evidentiary basis will be required to be
presented to the licensing authority
going back to the report there are a
number of
options available to the committee in
determining this application
and they are under 9.1
the options available are to modify the
conditions
to such an extent the members considered
necessary for the promotion
of the licensing objectives
the second option is to exclude from the
scope of the license
any of the licensable activities to
which the application relates
option three is to remove the designated
premises supervisor
four is to suspend the license for a
period and not exceed
in three months five to revoke the
license
six to leave the license as it is or
seven
to adjourn the hearing to a specified
date
or arrange for a hearing to be held on
specific
specified additional dates where members
can consider it necessary for the
consideration of any representations
or notice made by a party and that is
the end of the report
thank you mr greene has anyone as any of
the committee got any questions
please
no i can't see any hands up so i take
those no questions
mr greener
can i move on to councillor wilkinson to
please uh put his report in please thank
you
thank you chair uh chairman members um
i think it's important before i start to
explain
why i've called this review which
on the face of it is quite a drastic
application to make for premises within
your own ward
and and i have written something which i
i wish to
read out to you which i think and hope
will explain
my reasons for doing so and hopefully uh
will bring you up to speed with
um everything to do with this particular
premises
i'm here primarily to represent the
residents of alpha court
of court is a residential block of flats
which is immediately above
the subject venue of crafty casks
i hope members that you've had the
opportunity to read
seven letters of complaint which have
been submitted to the licensing
department as part of this review
process there are seven individual
letters of complaint in february 2019
when the original application for change
of use from a retail shop it was a
hardware store
was submitted residents in alpha court
contacted me with their concerns about
the potential noise and disturbance
which could result
in the licensed premises being permitted
directly beneath them
despite my representations to the
development committee last year
and again in the initial licensing
application stage both the change of use
and the license were granted the
licensee mr smith in his initial
application date of the 18th
february 2019 states that he wishes to
change the use of the unit from a shop
to a micro pub he then goes on to
describe what a micro pub actually is
saying it is and these are his words
they're saying that it is a well-run
premises
which tends to attract more mature
clients who are interested more in what
they drink rather than how much
they drink a picture german was painted
of a small pub
where craft ales would be served and
once a customer tried a couple of beers
they would leave
micro pubs do tend to be trouble free we
were told
so there was nothing for the residents
above but the premises to worry about so
far as disturbance and noise is
concerned
in fact mr smith draws a parallel the
three other venues in the local
area which are also micro pubs to
reassure the council during the
application stage that micropubs are
well-run establishments
in her report the planning officer at
the time in granting planning
and sent sites other micropubs in the
area and her personal experience of them
that they are well-run establishments
which tend to attract the more mature
clients
very similar wording in fact to that
used by the applicant in his application
it appears as though it is on this basis
that planning consent for the change of
use was granted
chair i called this application today
sorry i called this application at the
time to the development committee
and at the development committee meeting
i explained to the committee that whilst
the applicant
may well intend to create a small micro
pub which is very well run and does not
attract trouble changing the use to
allow a licensed premises will mean that
at that stage they can change from a
micropub
to a normal licensed premises at any
point they wanted to
my concerns were mainly due to the
ridiculous hours that were being
requested
12 hours a day seven days a week closing
at midnight
that is not consistent at all with any
other local micro
pubs hoppily which is in leon c
is open three days a week latest time of
closure
10 pm leon c brewing company
is open four days a week latest time of
closure
8 pm this particular premises wants to
remain open
seven days a week closing at midnight
it is a therefore great concern to me as
it was the residents of norfolk court
but in fact the applicants had no
intention of creating a micro pub
but it's interesting fact is in fact
just wanting to open
another bar in rayleigh the same sort of
the other bars which sell
all types of drink not just craft ales
and will attract
all types of customers which would
result in potential trouble and disorder
the development committee upheld the
office decision and cited actually it
wasn't for the planning committee
to regulate the buyers for licensing to
do so
so i tried a second time licensing but
failed and the only thing i managed to
achieve
was the installation of cctv uh which
actually
there's a benefit because it was shown
to you today chairman
in addition it was discovered that no
noise or soundproofing had been
installed
by the owners despite this being a
planning condition they had decided off
their own banks they didn't need it
having commissioned their own sound
survey thereby showing complete contempt
for council
banning department today this planning
condition has still not
been discharged and the planning
department enforcing officer said
in response to my question about this
that as this review is ongoing
nothing will be done until the outcome
of this review
the bar remained open in this manner for
several months and it caused no end of
nuisance to the residents above
um right from day one
completely ignoring any attempts from me
uh or the council to try
and deal with them despite a noise
abatement order
being brought to them and despite the um
environmental health team being involved
on several occasions
covert 19 eventually shot them for a
period of time so peace returned
once the government permitted bars to
open again the noise started again and
in some cases worse than before
you'll have read the letters how
residents cannot sleep with the windows
open some cannot sleep
at all as noise resonates through the
pub for the walls of the building rather
the bar chair has never been a micro pub
it has always been
another pub in rayleigh the owners allow
locking parties where there's usually
loud singing large groups of drunk
customers are regulated streets outside
singing and shouting
and in some cases fighting essex police
despite not
supporting this review have been called
there on more than one occasion to deal
with disorder
there are also a couple of letters in
support of crafty class
casks however those are patrons or
employees
of crafted casks
um right chairman members i have called
this review
for several reasons one is to protect
the residents in all for court
they have been living there for some
considerable time well before any
consent was given by rdc to change its
use
they used to live above a hardware store
which was shut after shopping hours
two the owners have completely
misrepresented misrepresented i would
submit
their intentions to the council in their
application this was never intended to
be a micro published from day one it
opened as a bar
attracting all sorts of customers
selling a wide variety of drinks not
just half dales
three the opening hours chair are
excessive they are open
far longer than any other micro pub in
this area
and there is clear evidence of this on
the license
of the licensees intention to sorry
there's clear evidence
or lack of evidence i should say of the
the licensee's intention to comply with
the law
as we can see and will see from the cctv
now chair i'm not suggesting at all this
premises should be closed
in any way this current economic
environment i applaud any business
that's able to keep going
however one year since it first opened
despite numerous interventions from
various sections of the council to get
them to change their working practices
they continue to ignore the police for
common sense they continue to ignore
what the council is trying to ask them
to do and you sent yourself chair
that or sorry stephen i should say said
there is still
um they haven't even the environmental
health
and the licensee haven't agreed they
still won't do what the department of
health are asking
it is less than a year from opening this
establishment has been warned about the
noise
it has failed to comply complete
discharge of planning conditions
there is um a live application has not
yet been discharged and they've been
further warned
by the council since covert restrictions
are lifted
i now respectfully ask each of you
members to carefully consider the impact
this bar
is having on those who live above it
would you wish to live there with the
current situation
i certainly wouldn't how can we better
protect the residents in all for court
the licensee himself has never once
interacted with any residents
who have complained in offer court to
work with them his son did once
but on that occasion he accused him of
lying because he didn't like what he was
told
uh figured me right which is
coincidentally they're
still their current position residents
must be lying must be exaggerating
the first thing i would ask is that
their opening hours are restricted chair
to a latest hour of 10 p.m
closure at the very latest on each and
every day they're open with a final sale
of alcohol no later than 9
30 pm give them half an hour to drink
the trouble which has been at the bar
has not just been on any particular
night this has not been on just weekends
it's been on both weekdays as well as
weekends and it's predominantly
after that time most of the time
i would invite you to consider if you
deem appropriate for the bar to be open
every day of the week
that of course is a matter for
yourselves
there is no security whatsoever at the
premises a condition of the license i
submit must be to include door security
seven days a week again i stress that
the trouble is also on weekdays not just
on weekends which is why it's needed
seven days a week
or is needed every day as you intend to
permit them to be open
the owners have proven they're incapable
of controlling the customers
they have voluntarily employed the door
staff on a couple of occasions who
actually have proved ineffective and
this has been witnessed
they may be due this may be due to
either who they've employed
or to the instructions given to them i
don't know which
either way effective door staff with
proper control over the customers is a
requirement
and needs to be a condition of the
license
they need to regulate drinking outside
the outside smoking area is
tiny absolutely tiny and generally
customers standing outside particularly
in the summer months block the pavement
the noise from these clients is a great
concern to the residents above
and this predominantly is causing the
problems i would suggest door staff do
not allow drinks to be taken outside
the area just simply isn't big enough
the actual licensee is very little to do
with this establishment and whilst
acknowledging that under the licensing
legislation he doesn't have to
physically be there
his absence and allowing his son to run
things is partly the reason things have
gone awry
mr john smith who is the licensee and as
such
we should require him to be on the
premises for a monitoring period until
they have proven
they can and do comply with conditions
one thing i'd just like to add chair is
as these are trophies under the
circumstances and it's with some great
disappointment
that i have to speak about uh miss smith
as who's on this call
who's appeared to change her mind um on
the venue and the fact this has in the
life of her children
chair i had the pleasure of speaking to
miss smith on on two occasions
uh once in person and once over the
phone on both occasions she was quite
forthright with me about the impact
that barr was having on her life and she
wanted to fully support
the review of the license she stated she
intended to submit a letter to the
council in support of the review
i had and indeed she did so i had reason
to speak with her on the phone a few
weeks back
after which after i was informed that
she might have been threatened or
intimidated
by the licensee's son to withdraw his
statement i managed to speak with her on
the phone that same evening and shearing
she reassured me that
that she hadn't been and whilst chris
smith had been
uh directly in contact with her um
it was because her statement was the
most damaging
about crafty casks and that was what the
nature of the conversation was
he wanted her to speak in defense of the
bar uh but she informed me that she had
no intention of doing so now clearly
she's changed her mind today
um i'm going to say two things in this
point chair first is i would urge
you and i'm happy if you were up if you
permit me to allow the chance to
question
later on i would urge you to examine and
fully investigate her reasons for
completely changing her mind and her
stance over this application
and secondly i would suggest
respectfully that has something to do
with the fact that um
since that conversation i had with her
she has formed a company called s
e cleaning um with another lady who
lives in there one who one of whom are
clients actually is the bar
so um and that's all over a facebook
page so that could well be the reason
why she's now supporting the supporting
the bar itself members to conclude
unless much titan controls are imposed
on this bar today by you
they will continue to daily ruin the
lives of those who live
above it enough is enough they've had a
year of this now they do not comply with
anything
like the council are telling them to do
they have had a whole year to sort
themselves out and have failed to do so
despite numerous warnings
please from us and a court order they
are still
arguing and they are not doing anything
that they're sorry they still argue
they're not doing anything wrong and
that everyone else is exaggerating this
is all a vendetta
chair that could not be further from the
truth look at the evidence
that that's there before you this
morning the allegations of drug abuse
the cctv evidence that we will be
viewing at the end not just by one but
several people including bar staff
behind the bar not just the customers
and the lack of control over the
customers and i would therefore
respectfully ask you please
today to impose stricter conditions on
their licence
so that they can trade but the residents
of alphacorp can live their lives
thank you chairman
thank you councillor wilkinson i haven't
got any questions at the moment but has
any
uh as councillor carol weston or
councillor phil shaw got any
carol weston councillor weston can you
please ask
thank you uh chairman um
i'm not sure who i should ask these
questions to but i will start with uh
councillor mike wilkinson um
council wilkinson have you ever been to
the crafty calf crafty cross
um venue of an evening at all it's a
quest is the first question
uh i haven't um uh council no
and there's a very good reason for that
um
because of my involvement right from the
start
before and before this um
premises even opened um
i didn't want to compromise myself i i'm
a lover of craftdale and i and i would
support the premises but i didn't want
to put myself in a
conflicting position so no i haven't
thank you
another question i'd like to ask is you
stated that
this is the only path that's open to 11
30 i think you said
um i'm not sure whether i should uh
direct this to you obviously steve
greener but i'm sure there are other
pubs in the area and is there not a
couple more um
um licensed premises down that road
near crafty cars that are open as well
yeah yeah no
you're you're you're exactly right uh
cancer western yeah no no what i said
was it's the only
micro pub in the area that's open till
midnight
it was open past 10 p.m
in my in my submission to you i said
that the this was initially
um this application was initially put to
the council not as just a licensed
premise not as a bar
but as a micro pub for the sale of craft
ale
that's what this application was a year
and a half ago
now what i'm saying to you is you are
quite right there's lots of licensed
premises around until 11 30 and beyond
and what i'm saying to you is that micro
pubs are not and this is what this this
premises wasn't was
was um was was aimed at being in fact is
now turned into another one of the ones
you're alluding to another bar blank or
another witherspoon or whatever that
turned into that's not what it was
reported to be and bearing in mind those
others are not directly below
uh licensed residential flats okay
another another question another so you
said you said about drug abuse etc has
there been any evidence by the police
that's been um
raided the premises to say there's been
any drug abuse within crafty crafts
at all uh councillor wilkinson
uh no to answer your question about the
police no there have been
that i know that have been intelligent
supports put into the police i know that
for a fact
um but i don't want to pre-empt what
siobhan sheridan is going to show you
because i think that might answer some
of your questions okay thank you
another question i want to ask whether
honest whether you should answer this or
whether your young lady should answer
this personally
on the flats um i noticed in one of the
um
in uh one of the young ladies saying
that she when she um
wants to get into her property there are
people standing outside her
front door is her front door from
eastwood road or is her front door
going like a stairs to the flats i don't
know whether you can answer that or
whether the young lady can answer that
at all
yeah share with permission i think it's
probably better that um but when you say
young lady who you're referring to
mr ellie i want you all okay oh hi
yes um yes that would be me um
you come through the front that's my
front entrance which is
crafty cast obviously front entrance and
i have a front and a back
um it happened once or twice and then i
did tell chris
um and i haven't had anything since that
because i do tend to come around the
back okay
can i ask another question on these
flats are they because i notice
you're saying that you're right above
that flat are you the only
lady who lives right above the space i
am yeah i am
directly above the flat so the pub sign
my flat
is um affected the modest basically
if if there's any problem then um i
yeah i'm the one that's affected i would
imagine anything
thank you sorry rebecca did you want to
say something yeah i i was just going to
say
through through the chair if uh
apologies for my interjection
i think miss smith is going to give her
um
evidence as a witness for mr smith
and questions can be asked of her at
that stage
um i i do understand obviously
from council western's point of view i
think the initial question was directed
to the applicant
um when when the party takes its
opportunity to
to give their um
make their representations the way the
procedure works is that they are then
can be asked clarifications by the
committee and by the other parties
if it's a question that they cannot
answer may i suggest chair that they
simply say
that that they are not the person to
answer and then
the question be put again at the
relevant point
it may assist i think otherwise we're
going to get representations coming in
that's fine sorry sorry yeah i'll come
back later
no questions at the moment thank you
thank you
okay can um the premises license holder
uh please speak on this
mr john smith you're on mute
mr smith are you not now right
okay um i'll be very
brief as i think i've covered most of
the things in my
written submission uh
first i'd like to say how much i
bitterly regret
recent events in particular those of the
7th
of august we had some difficulties
with live music when we first opened
because i believed that
without wishing to speak over mr smith
again
my apologies for interjecting yesterday
mr smith i i think
the chair was getting at the point that
this is your opportunity if you have any
clarification oh i'm sorry i'm sorry
mr wilkinson and then you will get your
opportunity to make your full
representations in due course so i think
i think that i write chair that you were
inviting mr smith
to ask any questions he may have of mr
wilkinson
yes i heard excuse me i've also got to
clarify on my list
it does go um
the council's licensing officer the
applicant the premises license holder
and any responsible authorities has that
changed
i i think you may have the old version
from the last time that was revised
apologies it is the council's licensing
officer the applicant any responsible
authorities
then any interested parties and then the
premises license holder
and any witnesses come within the
the time allocated for the
representations to be made
okay so that because that's what i've
just pulled down this morning so
um i do apologize so mr smith have you
got any uh clarification
anything you'd like to ask mr wilkinson
uh but not
put in just what else you would like to
say yeah
um no i think uh councillor
wilkinson has made his position uh quite
clear
thank you very much thank you i will now
go on to
um the environmental health uh miss
sheridan thank you thank you um
mr smith has no objection to the
statement of facts presented by me
and environmental health um as the
evidence is unequivocal
um the license holder has failed to meet
the license and objectives namely the
following
the prevention of crime and disorder so
on friday the 7th of august at 23
48 and sunday the 9th of august
at 6 minutes past midnight alcohol was
sold to members of the public
outside the premise licenseable hours
and therefore breaching
license conditions and not meeting the
licensing objectives
and screenshots of these transactions
taking place and can be found in my
exhibits
ss06 and these are on page 4.58
and 4.59 and 4.60
these are images of obviously the
transaction of the sale of alcohol
outside the license for hours
also on friday the 7th of august at 23
59
a male enters a single occupancy toilet
followed shortly by a second male
four minutes later both males leave the
toilet together
this type of behaviour is typically
associated with recreational drug use
and screenshots and cctv images and can
be found in my exhibits
ss06 and that's on page four point
six one and four point six two
um under the licensing objective uh
public safety
um on sunday the ninth of august at um
seven minutes past midnight chris smith
um
mr john smith's son can be seen lighting
a cigarette while standing behind the
bar
um he then hands the lighter to a member
of the public who is sat
on the other side of the bar for him to
light his cigarette too
both male and female bar staff also like
cigarettes behind the bar
with no hesitation indicating
and that this is common practice to
smoke within a smoke-free premises
um also another member of the public can
also be smoking despite the premises
displaying no smoking signs
the health act 2006 sets out that
premises that are open to the public
are used as a place of work by more than
one person
or where members of the public might
tend to receive or provide goods of
service
are to be smoke free in areas that are
enclosed or substantially enclosed
and the health act places the duty on
any person who controls or isn't
concerned in the management
of the smoke-free fences to cause a
person to stop smoking
however chris smith openly encourages
the smoking on the premises
also in regards to public health there
are lack of kovid controls in the
current climate in the middle of a
pandemic
and there appear to be no or little
control
in place to stop customers mixing with
other groups
or control the size of groups customers
were seen wandering across the whole of
the premises
and interacting with what appeared to be
other groups
and from reviewing the cctv footage on
the 7th of august
three customers were seen touching their
faces mouths
coughing or sneezing into their hands
and then shaking hands
hugging or in one case putting the hand
across the face of another customer
without washing or cleaning their hands
this is highly concerning
as it represents a high risk of
spreading the corona virus
the waitress and chris smith can be seen
hugging and shaking hands
with multiple customers collecting inch
glasses
and continuing to prepare customers
drinks without washing
or cleaning their hands in any way this
poor hand hygiene
presents a high risk of transmission of
the virus
at one point four customers started to
dance in a large space in the middle of
the floor premises
um and premises are not allowed to
function as a nightclub
as a practice of dancing in close
proximity
and to others is deemed to be high risk
and the spread of the virus
and no attempt was made by staff to stop
them dancing
this can be seen in stills taken from
the cctv
an exhibit ss07
under the prevention of public um
nuisance under the licensing
objective um complaints of noise and
anti-social behavior have been received
and on review of the premise of cctv on
the 7th of august
large groups of customers to the
premises frequently gather outside
the premises um um
and also glassware is taken out of the
premises
this is in the presence of chris smith
where he joins them outside
the doors are regularly left wide open
and the noise to escape the premises
um exhibit ss08 which is on page 4.63
and 4.64
the male in the blue t-shirt and beige
shorts
is christmas mr smith's uh john smith's
son
and also the female in the yellow blouse
he's holding a wine glass
whilst down the public highway outside
of the premises
i've been provided with footage from one
of my complainants
however i have not disclosed the footage
as the complainant was fearful of any
reprisal
i can confirm confirm having viewed it i
am of the opinion that the noise levels
on the 7th of august
were significant and were unreasonable
and would likely
have a detrimental impact on the
residents of ulfa court
also the cctv footage provided by the
premises on the 7th of august
women are dancing at the premises and
also in the open doorway of the premises
indicating that the music is at such a
level
um that it is no longer background music
or
incidental and due to the time of
dancing occurring
it falls under regulated entertainment
for which the premise is
not licensed for further breach in their
license conditions
exhibits ss08 on page 4.65
4.66 and 4.67
and demonstrate or and exhibit these
behaviors
um in the cctv skills
conditions were close to mr smith prior
to today's hearing
however mr smith does not want to be
held accountable with anything that is
enforceable
for example mr smith is happy to meet
the requirements of an action plan
in respect of door staff but he is not
prepared to have these as a licensed
condition
attached to his premises
to address some of the items raised in
mr smith's statement
i have to rebuff mr smith's claims that
the complaints
about the noise and the impact on
neighbours is exaggerated
previously a noise abatement notice was
served based on
fact and being within the complainant's
property at the time of the nuisance
occurring
not wishing to focus on the planning
conditions and that are still
outstanding
as these are a separate issue to
licensing it was raised to bring some
context into why the complaints are
being received from residents located
directly above the premises
and it is also a further demonstration
of mr smith's
inability to adhere to conditions put in
place by rightful district council
mr smith advises that there is a good
level of attenuation
and the noise level should have no
significant impact
on the residents is it unreasonable to
suggest that the noise arising from mr
smith's business
unlike any other business that has been
previously there
should have no adverse effect on the
residents of alpha court
mr smith claims that he does not permit
glasses
to be taken from the premises but this
is not the case
on the 7th of august a female can be
seen taking a glass
out the front of the premises on a
number of occasions
whilst congregating with of uh other
individuals
including chris smith who is responsible
for mentoring the bar
and is the son of mr john smith cct
footage
a week later on the 14th of august
between
22 53 and 2307
a 14 minute time span there are 10
separate incidents
of glassware having been removed from
the premises
um and that obviously concludes
obviously the evidence that i'm
presenting in regards to
the licensing objectives um other than
that i have tried to work with the
premises and have submitted
and proposed conditions to mr smith and
unfortunately we haven't been able to
agree
um on um some of the most
um serious conditions that would address
some of the anti-social behavior the
public nuisance side of things
for example door staff and in regards to
the
regulated entertainment side of things
in regards to playing of music
thank you very much um i noticed that uh
carol councillor carol weston wants to
have
uh ask a question for on the
subcommittee for clarification purposes
thank you council western thank you
chairman
uh siobhan um a few things really
has the licensee got at some some sort
of
polish procedures in place to do with
um with this license premises because
obviously i'm looking at if he's got
cctv
one of the things is does his staff know
that there's cctv and they can be picked
up on
anything so there's any policies and
pursuits in place for that
you talk about the noise level um
on the noise level how how do you
quantify the noise
level being over and above it should be
and
we also talked about bar stewards again
um because you talk about glasses being
taken outside the pub
and i noticed in one of the reports that
somebody said they saw one being smashed
on the
road or something um how do we how does
he
the um licensee quantify for that if
he's got a policy and procedure in place
on that
um and you also say about the action
plan the licensee is not prepared
to put this action plan in place and i
was just wanting to know why
what reasons are there that he doesn't
want to put a you know an action
plan in place saying that we've got
quite a few problems
and seeing that we have got the evidence
by cctv
sorry there's quite a few sort of
questions there thank you
and in regards to the cctv
um is a licensed condition it's a
requirement of their license to have
cctv
operational within the premises in
regards to whether the company
has a policy in regards to the staff
that's something that mr smith
should be able to answer for you um but
as i say i can confirm it is a licensed
condition
to have cctv within the premises in
regards to
addressing your um clarification in
regards to
uh noise and what levels and stats
nuisance
is um subjective so it's based on the
average person
so there aren't any noise levels set in
regards to a decibel level
that is being exceeded it's about what's
unreasonable
and a significant impact an unreasonable
effect on the material enjoyment
of somebody's property so at the time
when i undertook monitoring i was
within the complainant's property and it
was late in the evening
um around 9 10 o'clock that sort of time
maybe later
and when you can clearly hear somebody
um audible
on a microphone saying thank you very
much and
um singing and um it's very clear and
audible
then um we're in the realms of being
unreasonable because
it's not reasonable for somebody trying
to sleep within their premises
and they're being significantly affected
by noise generated
from the business below the premises um
and sorry you have to um
they're the last the action plan you
said there was actually
you want to put an action plan in place
and the um licensee did not want to
to do this because can you sort of
reiterate on that one please
so um licensing um
at rochefort district council have been
working with the licensed premises and
they have an action plan in place
um and the conditions that i were
proposing to the license holder
just uh basically replicates the action
plan
so the action plan set by stephen green
or his team
and in regards to the licensed premises
um has required mr smith to have door
stuff
and that has been happening as far as
i'm aware at the premises while the
premises have been operating
what i wanted to undertake with a
premise holder
is i um offered him the opportunity that
he could make
a um application
to alter his condition
so we could agree um and he doesn't
he didn't at the time want to commit to
licensed conditions prior to this day's
hearing
so can i come back chairman on that what
do you mean license
sorry um you'll have to explain that a
little bit more to the
uh to the committee yeah
um so um basically with license
conditions because they're attached to
their premise license they then become
enforceable so if mr smith
failed to adhere to those license
conditions then the licensing team
would be in a position to take formal
action
in regards to mr smith not adhering to
those license conditions
as i say rather than have an informal
agreement agreement with the premises
i wanted to make the conditions formal
but obviously
i have proposed conditions mr smith
wasn't um prepared to
um address the issues prior to today's
review hearing
so obviously um you have a copy of the
proposed license conditions from
environmental health
and obviously ask you to obviously
consider um the most appropriate course
of action
given the evidence that's really been
presented today
uh thank you sorry thank you um
i noticed steve greener would like to
say something but and of that i'd like
like to um miss sheridan's to actually
go through the conditions on page 4.22
so everyone's aware of them please
keep so you're aware that i will be
asking you that question
steve over to you yeah thank you very
much just to give a little bit of
clarity really
um because it is a little bit confusing
um if you
look at page 4.18 of the bundle
there is actually a copy of the license
conditions that are currently attached
to the premises license these were
agreed when the original license was
granted
in conjunction with essex police
environmental health
ourselves and other responsible
authorities
condition one talks about the cctv
requirement
and condition two talks about the cctv
signage so
it's clearly that there is cctv in the
premises
there is also condition 11 which talks
about
all staff engaged in the sale of alcohol
shall receive training
which again does cover a lot of the
licensing objectives
and condition 12 talks about training
records so again
there's a lot already in the license
conditions are already there
in relation to an action plan um i
followed the home office guidance
document
in relation to dealing with problem
premises and in
following the home office route map um
it
asks you to obviously trying to work
with the premises first to try
and deal with the ongoing issues and if
you can deal with those issues and
obviously there's no need to
support a review i can confirm john
smith and the premises
has been working with myself in relation
to an action plan
and that is still in place and it is
ongoing for us
hence the reason why the licensing
authority didn't make representation
against
uh in support of the review because we
are still continuing to work with the
venue
unfortunately as it's been highlighted
is a bit of a stalemate sort of position
with regards to environmental health
they have asked for conditions to be
attached to the license
some which do mirror the action plan and
i believe
john smith when he presents his case
will
highlight the conditions that he is
happy to agree
to have on the license subject to
obviously the committee
still allowing him to maintain the
license but there are some conditions
that haven't been agreed
between environmental health and mr
smith hence the reason why they've made
representation today
does that give a little bit more clarity
yes thank you i just wanted for the
whole committee to know that uh what the
full conditions were steven i know
councillor phil sure wants to speak
um councillor shaw can we go through the
conditions first please
so we are we all know what the
conditions are thank you
so the proposed conditions from
environmental health the first condition
was
a minimum of two security in security
industry
authority registered door staff to uh
will be employed
from uh 200 hours every friday and
saturday night
and the dps will assess the number of
and use
of door staff on other days times and
occasions
or where the police and licensing and
the dps will ensure
um a proper record is kept and to show
details of all door staff on duty
where the premises are providing a
takeout service only
then there is no requirement for door
staff this condition is already agreed
in principle through the action plan
with licensing
the only caveat includes included is to
recognize the current climate of
coronavirus
and in the event that the business is
only providing a takeout service
um unfortunately this condition wasn't
agreed with the license holder
um all windows and external doors shall
be kept closed
except where for the immediate access
and egress of persons
and this was agreed in principle with
the license holder
um notices shall be displayed close to
the entrance and
exit doors to the premises reminding
patrons of the residential area
nearby and asking res patrons to leave
the premises quietly
this too has been agreed in principle by
the licence holder
patrons permitted to temporarily leave
and then re-enter the premises
eg to smoke and shall not be permitted
to take
drinks or glass containers with them
agreed in principle by the license
holder
staff shall monitor customers smoking
outside the premises
on a regular basis to ensure patrons do
not cause
a public nuisance this was also agreed
in principle with a licence holder
um section 177 of the licensing act 2003
does not apply to the premises this was
not agreed with the license holder
if i give some clarification and so
basically under the live music
act the premises is able to have music
from the hours of 8 a.m
to 11 p.m without the requirement of it
being licensed
um or attached to the their license for
regulated entertainment
um by adding this condition um
it removes um that um availability to
have
the deregulation of the live music act
so that
basically requires them that they won't
have any music
whatsoever at the premises um however as
an
alternative condition um we did suggest
that a um tamper-proof uh noise limiting
uh device um shall be fitted to the
sound system within the premises
and all amplified music played at the
premises
must must pass through sound limiter at
a level agreed by the council's
environmental health section
the noise limiter shall not be altered
without prior agreement with the
council's environmental health section
while live or recorded music takes place
the licensee
and all management shall undertake
regular monitoring
of noise levels at the nearest noise
sensitive locations
and a record shall be kept of any
monitoring including the date
time and location of the monitoring the
name of the mantra
and any action taken record shall be
kept for no less than six months and
shall be made available upon request by
a police officer or an authorised
officer of rocha district council
and then lastly no waste or recyclable
materials including bottles
and shall be moved removed from or
placed um in outside areas between 2 300
hours
and 0 800 hours on the following day and
again this condition wasn't made in
principle by the holder
uh like a license holder
thank you very much i noticed councillor
wilkinson you have your hand up after
uh councillor shaw then you'll be
invited to do for clarification
thank you councillor shaw
thank you chair um just a question about
the
um sound levels i understand
that um some readings were taken
of the sound levels in in the flats was
this at the request of the flat owner
um in regards to my investigation in
regards to a noise nuisance complaint
that i'd received
um i was in the flat directly above the
premises
and that was on request by the occupant
of that premises
there weren't particular noise readings
as i say for statutory nuisance
and there isn't a set decibel level it's
about what's unreasonable
and what's having a significant impact
on the material enjoyment of somebody's
property
thank you thank you council wilkinson
thank you um siobhan a couple of
questions if i may
just referring to the the sound checking
that you were doing um
you're saying it was a flat directly
above the premises um i believe there
are a couple of flats directly by the
premises but miss sally smith has said
she lives directly above the premises so
we talk about the one in the same flat
uh yes we are so the sound checks that
time took place in eddie smith's flat
that's correct okay and the
i think i'm right you said that the uh
it's a subjective test there isn't a set
decibel level
but whatever your views were um
and your opinions were you took those to
a noise abatement order was that issued
by yourself or by a court
uh the noise abatement is issued by
myself
um i was the witnessing officer i was in
attendance at the premises
um and the noise abatement is to
prohibit basically a reoccurrence of the
same
so basically it's um
um it's a formal document um and any
breaches to that document if they're
witnessed by
an officer um then it would result in
um legal action in regards to that all
right sorry okay that's fair enough
just one other thing i was going to ask
you and one of the conditions that you
recommended to the
to the committee around was around door
start from fridays and saturdays i'm
just curious as to why you've narrowed
it down to those two days because
as i'm sure you're aware in my
submission to the panel i
i said it should really be every day
they're open because
my experience my experience the the
information i'm getting from those who
are affected by this premises that it's
not just at weekends it's
there's been a number of incidents
during the week as well so i'm curious
to know why you've only recommended the
weekends um it's really in reflection to
other licensable premises within the
area in regards to
um some continuity in regards to license
conditions throughout the railing and
obviously each premises
is individual and therefore um you know
it is
needs tailoring to each individual
premises and that's why there is a
caveat in
that um condition in regards to um
um the dps will assess the number and
use of door stuff on other days
um so you know as a business person
you have to be a responsible person for
running your premises
um and also obviously and that's in
conjunction
with um obviously essex police and the
licensing department
and so there is that caveat there if um
if it was necessary to run
monday um yeah sunday to thursday in
regards to additional door stuff
um or even for bank holidays or where
and public holidays like christmas and
that fall um not on a friday or saturday
and that allows this condition to to
work right across the board really
okay so i'll be right in saying then
that your
your recommendation is based on um
conforming to the norm within rayleigh
as opposed to specifics for the
supremacist
um it's just in regards to the evidence
that's been made available to me
um most of the evidence that i've uh
have
has been made available to me has been
predominantly at the
the weekends um but as i say i can't
really comment in regards to what's
happening during the way and because i
haven't been privy to that
that that okay okay all right fair
enough i i i thought you had been
because i have about uh stuff during the
week and i thought you had been as well
but that answered the question thank you
thank you french i can't see anyone else
uh wanting to ask uh any questions
is there no so i'm not gonna go on
i think mr greener um had his hand i'm
sorry
you haven't got your hand up no shaking
your head steve or noddy
no nothing from myself um i didn't know
if there was any questions that uh
mr smith wanted to see clarity from miss
yes mr smith
have you any uh clarification only
questions for miss sheridan
yes um hello mr sheridan um
the the only thing i really wanted to
talk about was the um
the uh the door staff as to
why uh you wanted
um the door stuff to be put in as a
condition of the license
rather than relying on the flexibility
of the
um action plan that we already have in
place
um i've given undertakings to stephen
greener
um that i would have
um
i would comply with the action plan uh
indefinitely
so as the conditions uh changed
so i'd be happy to change the number of
door staff
for instance when we went on to level
two our
um turnover plummeted by about 75
and stephen greener agreed that
in that case we only needed one door
staff
and in fact the door staff said we
didn't need anybody because
at some stage stages on friday and
saturday the
number of staff we had on outnumbered
our customers
so i i feel that uh
mr smith is asking for clarification are
you making a statement please
sorry yes uh
yes i i slipped into making a statement
i'm i'm very sorry
but uh i just wondered why um
siobhan uh
wanted a formal change rather than
um the informal um
situation we already have thank you uh
miss face sheridan
right and so in regards to your question
um obviously we are currently in the
middle of a pandemic but i don't
anticipate that this
will be the new norm at some point we
will
um obviously um come through this and um
be acting and so the conditions are in
regards to the longevity
um for as long as you're a licensed
holder and
so um and also the reason to put them
as part of the license conditions is
because to make them enforceable
um obviously there is evidence that you
struggle to
maintain or meet the license conditions
already in place
and so therefore i think it's reasonable
and to put a condition in
that is enforceable rather than relying
on the goodwill
of somebody who hasn't currently been
running the
the premises in a fit and proper manner
thank you very much i can't see
i'll have a look i can't see anyone else
up with their hands
uh nope so we will now move on to the
premises license holder
and you'll have a opportunity to present
your submissions you will have 15
minutes and
if you would like to go down mr smith
apologies chair if i need to check again
i think i think there may be an
interesting party
okay is it either is the interesting
party
uh yes
yes all right sorry you're you're it's
your opportunity
to speak and you're getting you'll have
15 minutes okay thank you
and my name is larissa eid and i'm
making representation
on behalf of some of the residents of
alfa court
and i'd like to thank you for giving the
opportunity to speak today
first of all can i point out that myself
and my fiancee paul smith
are not averse to the idea of a micro
pub it is operational within its
licensing conditions
and there is no personal vendetta
against either mr john smith
his son or the business one of the
residents
mrs g smith wishes to state that she
remains the resident of olfa court
and has been for over 25 years she would
like to stress
that in lockdown for the sake of her
health and safety she stayed at her
partner's residence in surrey
since lockdown was lifted she has been
returning regularly but feels she could
not return perfectly due to the
disturbances caused by crafty casks
on the subject of letters a couple of
the residents didn't have access to a
computer or printer
therefore they asked me to help
articulate their grievances in a manner
that was acceptable for a licensed
review
missy smith was one of the residents
that reached out and asked me for help
i did all of this in good faith and i
find the current accusations that i have
written a letter
for her and forced her to sign very
upsetting and distressing
i can only assume that her u-turn is
either due to her belief the letter was
anonymous
or is connected to the fact that since
submitting her letter she now works for
the company
that cleans crafty casts on a regular
basis
if required i can produce evidence in
this hearing to support my assertion
that miss smith approached me and was in
full agreement of me assisting with her
letter
the reason i feel i need to talk to you
today is to address the detrimental
effects the day-to-day running of crafty
casts is having on mine and my fiancee's
mental and physical health
our main issue is the level of noise
created by the bars patrons who
congregate
be it weekend or weekday for long
periods of time
on the pavement outside the bar beneath
our living room window
neither of us could be approved but the
shouting foul language and altercations
have been a constant disturbance
into the early hours repeatedly night
after night
after night during the summer months the
level of noise was so intolerable that
we were unable to hear our television
or open our windows even on the hottest
of days as i'm sure you would agree
everyone has the right to be able to sit
down and relax in the comfort
of their own home unfortunately this
riot has been denied us
and instead is causing us to experience
stress anxiety and depression
rather than being able to enjoy the
summer months we found ourselves
dreading a nice warm day
and we feared it would trigger an influx
of patients on
to the bar on the pavement outside i
must emphasize
that we have no escape from the noise as
even in the sanctuary of our own bedroom
shouting and singing can still be heard
paul smith has voiced these issues with
the licensee's son
on a couple of occasions but was met
with a defensive and dismissive attitude
in fact response was you should just
accept it you live on the high street
however it was pointed out to him we
actually live on the eastwood road in a
residential block
we can see the noise levels of crafty
cast has been more horrible in the past
few weeks
but we fear this could be due to the
worsen weather and the new coveted
10 pm curfew our concern is when the
curfew is lifted the situation will
revert
neither of us feel we could tolerate
another summer living under these
conditions
i would also like to bring your
attention that since the bar has opened
we have had no contact with the licensee
mr john smith
we assumed he was aware of the problems
but no attempts were made on his part to
reconcile our differences
actually until last week i wouldn't have
known what mr john smith looked like
i've had my concerns about speaking
today for fear of reprisal
but i have plucked up the courage as i
felt it was imperative
to express our views and concerns whilst
we have the opportunity
thank you again for your time and i
trust you will take what i have said
into consideration
thank you very much i know tissa
councillor carol weston has got her hand
up uh
asking for clarification points please
councillor weston
thank you uh arista can i just say what
a lovely
concise report thank you very much for
that thank you
where do you live do you live in the
flats or do you live on the road
yet along the east coast we live in the
flat so our flat is actually above
bentley's calf but our joining wall
um is actually adjoining boards crafty
crafts
where's your front door so our front
door is actually at the back of the
flats but our
living room window the high street so it
overlooks eastwood road
so that's getting issues from the people
congregating the noise outside
and the other young lady you were
talking about where does she live does
she live next to you or did she get
further down the flats
no she lives below us so we live we're
not directly above where
we're sort of that we're the third level
up and she's
directly below the flat she's at the
back of the prophecy though there is
another flat next door to her that's
directly above him
so can i just clarification is there two
lots of flats is there a top lot
in the middle yeah so there's three
floors so you've got
a set of flats and then another set of
flats on top we're on the top floor
um an accident that's directly above is
mr burgess who has also submitted a
letter
just another quick question before
crafty car craft cross opened
there's other public houses down there
what sort of them
um noise did you get from them
jj whispers we don't really get much
noise from them i'll be honest with you
that there is
they they they have staff and they keep
their doors shut and if there's anybody
outside making noise they do ask them to
obviously you know
keep it down because there are residents
um above
them we don't really have any issues
with them thank you for your time today
thank you thank you
thank you
thank you mr councillor shaw have you
anything
any clarification
you're a mute and you've stopped your
video
you're still on mute
all right thank you um the question was
the you say you actually
um typed up a couple of letters for
other residents this was at their
request
and no pressure was put on them to do
this
no no pressure thought is that their
request and i i like i said i actually
have
evidence of a text message um between
myself and miss smith
um to back that up if needs be
thank you okay there's no other
uh questions from the subcommittee um
other parties may only ask questions of
the interested parties
um but it's a clarification only purpose
only is there anyone please
i can't i don't know if you can all put
your hat blue hands up or anything
or i'll just go through the screens to
have a quick look
have you got a thumbs up
no nothing thank you lori so that was a
good presentation thank you very much
right mr smith it is now your turn to
put your opportunities
forward and again you will have 15
minutes
um could i ask for um ellie smith to
make her
statement first yes of course
yeah that'll be fine oh yeah
so um i would like just to say um
that this whole time that this whole
thing has been going on
um that yes i have felt pressurized into
doing this
um i've had numerous people knocking at
my door
saying that um it's my responsibility
because i live
directly above crafty casks um
yes i did put a complaint in um purely
for the fact
that larissa did say to me that she was
putting hers in so i said okay
i might as well put a written statement
in as well
um i'll be completely honest at the
beginning
when the crafty cast opened it was bad
um i did speak to chris about this and
um a couple of times there wasn't really
anything coming back from when it and it
still carried on
and so then i got obviously siobhan um
coming around my flat and she was doing
um like a noise thing from my children's
bedroom
um which was pretty bad and then
obviously lockdown had come along
and obviously nothing it was closed down
um after lockdown i think it was about
two weeks
probably after lockdown there was a
fight outside
um but that wasn't from because i spoke
to the lady who was actually in that
fight
um and because i was really concerned um
that was coming from oyster wolf which
has
just recently opened um
and yeah so basically i you know i i
haven't
and i i don't understand why you're
saying that i've been threatened
um councillor mike wilkerson because i
haven't
i haven't i haven't been friend and i
actually spoke to stephen greener
on the phone i believe because i had a
voicemail left to say that i had been
friend
if i had been friend i can assure you
that
um matters probably would have been a
lot worse
i don't condone violence in the
slightest but
you know if i had been threatened it
probably would have been settled another
way
um and chris would have been actually
told face to face if i'd been friend i
hadn't been friend
and as for i now work in um
crafty casks pub no i don't it's
actually my business department works
down there
so that's that's a complete lie as well
as saying that i have been
um i think i've actually cleaned in
there once
i don't and i haven't done it since that
was to help my business partner out
um i just feel really upset by the fact
that larissa
is now saying that um i'm going against
it when she knows for a fact that she's
been looking that she has been knocking
on my door
she's been knocking everybody else's
door upstairs asking for um
a statement and i was the only one
because i you know i do have really bad
mental health issues
and she knew at the time i was going
through a really bad stage because i'm a
single mum with two children
that i was going through a really bad
stage um and i'm just really upset to be
honest
and i'm not saying that crafty cast have
been
you know angels they haven't and i have
said this to chris
and to john smith um and i have seen
that they have got bouncers
um at the door now and since that i can
honestly say
i have no issues i've said this to
larissa and i said this to mike
wilkinson
when he actually turned up at my flat
unannounced
um and i opened the door and he come in
he said oh you know i've been trying to
get through to you for a few weeks
he i'm sorry but i don't want people
knocking at my door i also had someone
from upstairs it wasn't larissa
and i also had someone come downstairs
and they said to me and it and it really
upsets me
and they basically said to me that this
is your
it's my fault and that um i'm the one
that lives directly above it
and i'm basically an irresponsible
parent because i haven't put a complaint
in i'm a really laid back person
um and i've got two small children to
worry about
and i'm not the sort of person to want
to get anything closed down and i
wouldn't do that
um but i do feel like from sort of after
lockdown i
have been pressured up pressurized into
there
thank you very much
i would also like to say sorry
i would also like to say that my
children aren't in any sort of
danger the only reason that i have i
said that in my statement was because
there was a fight that had broke out
around the back um
and that was coming from oysterwolf that
wasn't coming from crafty casks
okay you that's what you've already
stated thank you i see um
councillor mike wilkinson and councillor
carol weston have both got their hands
up
cuts the white wilkins would you like to
ask um
miss smith for clarification please on
any items she stated thank you
uh i'm i'm happy to chair but um
i'll obviously concede to get to
accounts of western issues remember your
committee
yeah okay first but i do have questions
thank you chad yes of course thank you
uh council western thank you chairman hi
ellie i'm i'm i'm very sorry that you've
been putting pressure on on to you i'm
you know that
that's that's not that's not good i just
wanted to i think i've been clarified
for what i wanted to ask you anyway just
your you live um where you live in in
that block
i am i led to believe that you live on
top of
crafty crafts is that is that correct
yeah so i live directly above
crafty cast i live um i would say where
the toilet area is
and um the bar and the side of crafty
car
all right that's all i want to know
thank you i'm sorry again for your
problems
thank you yes cancer sure
i just want to i just want to clarify um
from uh miss smith that she actually
did contact the environmental health to
come around
to do a read or because of the noise
yeah that's correct but that was um when
it first had opened
um and that's yes that's when it was bad
and i won't you know
it truthfully it was bad then um
and i had addressed chris and i
obviously i couldn't get anything
he wasn't really answering that's when
um obviously me and larissa then started
talking and also paul
they were coming down to my flat moves
having conversations about it
um and then i believe um
andy and jill that used to live that
i've not seen them there for a few
months now for probably about four or
five months
um that i think that they they um jill
come down a couple of times
um but yeah i just i
just i don't mean not to say really i
just i'm really upset by the fact that
larissa is
by what she's saying right
and the other thing was you said that
you haven't cleaned there other than
once
but your business partner has so in fact
it is still
a business that you're involved with
that's doing the cleaning
yeah we do have a business um but i will
do
my own things and she will do her own
things she has been
um she has been doing that i think since
it's opened
i and i didn't i've only just really
started getting into business with
stacy who actually lives next door to
larissa
thank you chair
if you were inviting me to speak sure
you were muted
that makes a change doesn't it thank you
yes i was
thank you for lip read thank you
and ellie i i just wanted to clarify a
couple of things
in what you're saying for the benefit of
the committee because i think it's
important to do so
um i when i came around to see you yeah
i had been trying to get ahold of you
for for a while because every time i was
in the block talking to all the
residents at the time who contacted me
um you weren't in um so i was constantly
come back because i needed to speak to
everybody
um which is why i i did come back to
your flat and when i spoke to you of
course and as you said obviously this is
why i
started to think that things were quite
bad and at that time did you feel as i
put any pressure on you to um
to to make a complaint to the council um
mike to be honest i i hate confrontation
and i'm one of these people that just
want to make everybody happy but
yeah i did at the time i felt pressured
by one of the residents that was
upstairs and he kept coming down
um and saying that you know i thought
it's my
problem i should be the one doing it
because i live directly above it and i
have children
and it's my responsibility um it wasn't
just you
mike that had come around i'm not saying
it was just you that put me under
pressure but i
i have felt under pressure with it all
especially towards the end i mean at the
beginning
it was bad but um and i wish that i'd
put a
you know a written complaint in then and
that this written complaint hadn't gone
in
this time because it's just and to be
honest i didn't even type the the letter
yes i did uh larissa was there and i did
say to louisa
could she she did it for me because she
had the laptop
um and i think she'd done somebody else
as well but to be honest
excuse me can you just start with some
uh counselor mike yeah
the other thing i was going to say was
um uh
ellie and then we had a conversation a
couple about a month or so ago
um and just to clarify that for the
benefits of the committee
yeah um i i
i never said you were you were
threatened because i don't know i was
given information
that you were being threatened yeah okay
um
and so i naturally was very concerned
um by it and in actual fact i even
involved essex police in it i was that
concerned
and i stood them down once i got hold of
you because i couldn't get hold of you
to start off with
now you remember the conversation that
we had
but do you remember us talking um oh
yeah yeah i remember talking yeah
now that wasn't that long ago so at that
time
you said to me exactly what you said to
the committee today that had he
threatened you you would have
dealt with it yourself which reassured
me but you also said to me that you
that that you're still fully supporting
the review for this application
so my question is what has changed
between then
and you putting your revised um letter
in what's changed
i've not i've might i haven't this is
the thing that's really winding me up
because i
actually said to you when you were
standing in my living room and i was
standing in the kitchen
that i was more than happy to
support crafty cast and say that they
had got better
and that i would was more than happy to
support you
and larissa and everybody else that was
against crafty casks
and say yes it was bad because i did
have um javon around my house
um you know this whole thing especially
the end of it has come from being i just
feel so
so pressurized i've even been i've i've
had to go to the doctor about it because
i just
it's awful and i don't want to be made
to feel like i'm a bad parent
because i didn't put that complaint in
because it you know but with the noise
and i totally agree with you ellie and i
and i and i don't condone whoever said
that to you
yeah um but but but what i'm trying to
get at is that you you're saying you
feel pressurized
um but you've changed your story i'm not
saying that that's
not i would phrase it i apologize no no
i apologize i'll change that you haven't
changed the story you've changed your
statement for once about a phrase
you've taken i haven't wrote no i didn't
write no statement no i just
i just give him my complaint and it was
written down on the left
yeah okay but you put a new one in so
what has happened to prompt you to do
that who's pressurized to do that then
so obviously there was complaints that
before lockdown
which when i said it was bad then
lockdown had happened
and then obviously chris uh sorted
dormant out
um i actually had a conversation with
chris as well
and there were certain people that he
wasn't allowing back in the past because
it was certain people that were actually
making this
noise um and smashing glasses and
um since then they have they haven't
been there because they used to park
around the back
and i haven't seen them since that
conversation with chris
now chris i i did have um a bit of a
tiff with chris because i said to him
you know he's taking the mick you know
i've got two small babies i'm on my own
i don't get any help
um and i i just i don't know the whole
the whole time i mean not at the
beginning
it was absolutely fine you know i was
happy to put my complaint in
after lockdown that's when i feel as
though i was being
pressurized by just a couple of people
like by obviously the neighbors
and uh counsellors basically
sorry mike but yes by people coming
around my house and i
i feel a little bit intimidated right
thank you
um council wilkerson don't cross
examination it's just for clarification
please
i i'll leave that there then
thank you and um miss sheridan
would like to speak thank you it was
just really to bring about
some clarification um ellie smith did
um contact me um last year in regards to
the noise arising from the premises and
that's when the noise abatement was um
served on the premises um i can confirm
um she also
contacted um mid-august and that was
prior to the review being called
in regards to a complaint of noise and
we had a conversation
um in regards to the noise arising from
the premises
and that we were obviously going to be
following our standard procedure in
regards to investigating the noise
and so just to confirm ellie smith
hasn't complained just once
um it has been more than on than one
occasion
and that was mid-august prior to the
review being called
thank you very much is there anyone else
i'm going to flick through the screen
just to see if anyone else
is putting the thumbs up or a hands up
look on the screen mr smith
would like he's got his hand up
miss smith you're a mute i'd just like
to
um clarify with uh ellie
um the way i understand it is
that there was a problem last year when
we had the music on
and there hasn't been a problem since is
is that the case
there was a problem yeah obviously when
it all
was really bad and i spoke to chris and
then a couple of weeks
after lockdown i believe there was a
fight that broke out and i was really
angry about it
because my children were up but i
actually had the conversation with a
girl
that had um had actually got hit by this
man in the middle of the road
um and it was because i had asked them
and they said that they'd come out of
oyster wolf and i was actually sitting
oyster wolf
with my children prior to that and i did
actually see them sitting in there
um but i i'm sure i made the complaint
obviously before
um lockdown and then that one complaint
i think i'm not sure i think it might
have been
siobhan maybe that i'd spoke to um and i
just said because louisa had come down
and she said also said that she wasn't
happy obviously about what had gone on
um so i'd called um i think it might
have been shivan but if i'll be
completely honest with you
half the time because of the medication
i'm on i don't
my mind's just like a blur if i'm honest
okay
so to be to be clear the complaint you
made in
august wasn't relating to our premises
no it was about a fight that had broke
out okay thank you
right right okay sorry can i just say
one more thing before
you go yes sorry
yep so there was um i mean sorry ellie
is this clarification
on the question you've been asked not to
go over what you've already said
because we've heard it's a fight how and
it doesn't affect
uh crafty crop cast we don't need to
know that anymore
right we don't we only need to have a
clarification yeah please yeah okay
so just to clarify also there was um
some loud music coming from craftycast
which was at the back that was just
after lockdown
um that obviously that i wasn't happy
about but i did speak to chris about
this
and um he then decided to keep the back
doors locked
and obviously think that i've not had
anything
okay thank you right mr smith it's down
to yourself you have now
got ten minutes to speak okay thank you
sorry it's taking a while well
i i won't be very long i'll be very
brief as i think
uh i covered most of the things in my
written uh submission um
i bitterly regret the recent events uh
especially those of the seventh of
august
we had some difficulties with live music
when we first opened
um because i believe that our
soundproofing was good
i expected the planning condition to be
discharged before
october 28 last year i applied for the
discharge of our conditions
um 16 weeks before it was finally
rejected
on the 22nd of december we have not
played
any live music since the noise abatement
order was served on us
we went through the busy christmas and
new year period
without a problem despite environmental
health misgivings about us being allowed
to open late
on new year's eve since then we've
installed some more sound proof in
in the area that we believe was causing
a problem and hope to have our
soundproofing condition discharged quite
soon
um even on the 7th of august it doesn't
seem to have
been a problem with loud music
i'm very happy to have a sound limiting
system installed by
any professionally accredited company to
ensure that the sound level from the bar
doesn't exceed um
whatever the prescribed limit is
i understand that um talent masuku from
planning
and andrew padden from environmental
health
are in discussion about this matter and
i hope that they'll be getting back to
me in the next
week or so um we had no
further problems with noise until the
recent complaints and i feel
that there have been attempts to suggest
that our recent
problems are actually a general problem
going back to last year
however this is not the case
um i think it's uh
regrettable that none of the neighbours
have ever complained to me
directly i know larissa was
saying uh that
i hadn't reached out to her but um
really if she has a problem she should
complain with me
and i would like to engage with her in
fact
going forward i'd like to engage with
her and the other
um neighbors if they have a problem
and i'm sure we can get it resolved
since i received the email from
licensing regarding the complaints i've
worked
closely with them and we have an action
plan agreed which i believe has put us
back on the straight narrow
their guidance and help have been
invaluable and i appreciate all the time
they've devoted to us recently
especially
stephen greener i'm very glad that
neither they nor essex police have
decided to support this review
preferring instead to rely on the
measures already in place
i also received
an email from environmental health about
the incidents on around
the 7th of august and i suggested we
could work
together to resolve the problem using
the the action plan already agreed on
with licensing but um they prefer to
take another route
i'm extremely unhappy about the events
of 7th of august
and i think um siobhan has demonstrated
that it wasn't our finest hour
however i do take issues with the
suggestion that
she had to with hold video evidence
for fear that we would uh retaliate
against
um the person who provided the video
and the the same with larissa that she
felt
intimidated that for some reason well
that she felt in fear that we would
retaliate against her
i mean i i think that's well a terrible
thing to say
i think uh craftycast has been portrayed
as some sort of
wild west hellhole when in reality
we're a small independent venue
that serves the community well
um thank you that
that's all i have to say
thank you very much can i just ask early
can you sort your device out because
you're actually making me feel seasick
bobbing up and down
it's just that you're bobbing up and
down it's making me
okay just get yourself salty so you're
comfortable for this because you need to
be comfortable
as well okay uh carol weston
uh councillor carol weston you've got
your hand up uh clarification questions
please
i just asked one question please um
mr smith um you are the license holder
of the premises
yes and are you there on the premises
every
day night our end or is there another
person within the premises who is also
has a license to sell alcohol please
um i'm not there
certainly not all the time i wouldn't
say even most of the time
although recently i have been spending a
lot a lot more time there
um we have uh one other
well we actually had uh two other
license holders now
um
emilia coppins has been a license holder
for
a number of years and
my son has recently
been granted a license so we have three
license holders all together
yes of course yes when you say
amelia cobbins when did she get the
license and when did your son get the
the license
uh my son got his license uh within the
last
week um emilia copkins has had one
for uh a number of years
um she comes from uh
a a licensed premises family her
her mother was a licensed holder and uh
she was brought up in a pub as far as i
know i don't know how long she's had the
license
but great question so was there any time
on your premises either these two people
either these people were not on the
premises and you weren't on the premise
at the time
in when they when the crafty cross was
open we don't always have a license
holder on the premises no
we're a very small venue and most of the
time
we have few customers so normally
there's just one member of staff on
um okay thank you we're not
an out and out pub we're um
we're a small bar in a shop shop unit
thank you i've got one question for you
smith you're saying you're not a bulb
but you're selling
um alcohol and you have a seating area
sorry no we are above bar we're not a
traditional pub
we're not a large pub we're we're you
don't need to be a large pub to sell
alcohol you're still selling alcohol
and you've got people sitting down
you're not a takeaway you're not like
a takeaway service i'm just clarifying
this are you you just don't
so sorry i i was talking about uh the
number of staff
we have on any one time and uh whether
we're likely to have
a license holder on um we have uh
one two three four
all together we have five staff and
uh three of them are now license holders
okay um councilor phil shaw
thank you chair um one of one of the
conditions is that um alcohol
shouldn't be consumed outside the
building and we've heard in one case
before looking at the pictures 4.63
there seems to be a gentleman outside
drinking as well he has a glass in his
hand there doesn't seem to be anybody
stopping
people going out there with glasses
sorry is that a question to me yes yes
yes i i must admit we have had a lack of
control
um of people taking glasses outside
it's not something we want and we have
taken steps
to um to stop this
uh before we had the door staff on on
friday and saturday nights
uh we did put an extra member of staff
on um to look after
to look after the floor um including
um checking to make sure that nobody was
taking glasses outside
um
it's not something we want i mean
um we don't want people outside the
glasses
we we just want people to go outside to
smoke and then come back
and again noticing on these pictures
the doors are left open again
that is uh contravening the the
conditions isn't it the door should be
kept closed
yes we we have a a plan in place
that i wanted to discuss with
environmental health
where we would put on a second set of
doors inside
to create a small vestibule
so that it would uh we could guarantee
to have
a set of doors closed um at all times
all right thank you thank you um
i believe yes counselor mike wilkinson
thank you thank you mr smith
um i wonder if you could um explain to
the committee if if i may ask because it
comes to something that i i mentioned
about um
about the type of premises you are you
you said that you're you're a small pub
or a small bar or a problem with the
exact phrase that you said
um and you're not like the other the
others in in in raleigh
how do you think you differ then and why
is it you feel necessary to remain open
till midnight when all the other micro
pubs in the area don't what
what makes you different from them um
i was talking about when i spoke earlier
i was
really talking about the size
of our premises and the number of staff
that we're likely to have on at any one
time
oh okay so why why okay okay so the
regards the time though
that's the point i'm i i think it's
important why
why you want the bar to stay remain open
so much longer than the other micropubs
in the area do because that's what
you're saying your premises
is um we're we're a craft bar
um more along the lines um
of the ale house in um in chelmsford
um that's not anything
application sorry
sorry chair i'm going to end it from the
on the ground
i don't need a proper way of challenging
the inappropriate comments that have
been made because i don't you've been
misled because
i'll take guidance on that but um
um yeah it was just clarify you said in
regards to the taking of glasses
outside um but can you clarify in
regards to
um exhibit ss08 4.63 and
point six four that is your son outside
with the female in the yellow blouse
that has a glass
um outside the premises and she wasn't
challenged
um to take the glass in so in regards to
what you're saying not permitting
glassware outside that's
not actually the case yes i've
i haven't challenged any of your
evidence and i have put my hand
up to the unfortunate
events um on that evening and
i must say it wasn't um
probably an isolated incident but we
have tightened up
uh
since then and we do not allow
glasses um outside
um it's
it has actually been quite difficult to
enforce but our customers are becoming
more educated now um
and i don't believe we have a problem
with glasses going outside now um
we seem to have uh fewer people smoking
outside as well
we have fewer customers at the moment
but um
no i believe we had this under control
thank you i can't see anyone else asking
questions um
so am i right in saying sonia we'll come
off the live stream
to look at now look at the um cctv
or are we going rebecca might be able to
help me are we going to do any closing
statements first what would you suggest
please
chairman sorry i'm not sure whether am i
allowed to
ask steve green a question or is that
not
uh in the in this thing now uh
your advice rebecca please
um i i think we're taking it a little
bit out of order but
um it's a matter of bu if it's for
clarification on on
something that mr smith has said that uh
mr greener can assist with then
i think it would be open to you to allow
that and then i would suggest um
because the parties have all agreed that
they're happy for the cctv to be shown
and you've agreed that um
that you don't require any commentary on
it to be shown at the end i suggest
closing
submissions first a little unusually
simply because of the streaming issue um
but that will allow the closing
submissions to be streamed
and then the matter can be brought to an
end on the streaming but the meeting can
continue publicly with all the parties
present and the cctv can be sharing
thank you very much for clarification
councilor weston to
steve greener please yes steve can i
just ask a question am i right in
thinking
when selling alcohol the um the
losses holder uh or anybody who is
selling alcohol you have to have
a a license on uh on in the premises
um and i just wanted to find out also
the license holder has to um
show or have their certificate on show
to say that they have they have a
license to sell alcohol i was just a bit
concerned where
mr smith said that sometimes he doesn't
have a license hold on the premises and
they are selling
alcohol perhaps you can just clarify
that for me please
yes i can confirm that the guidance
under the 182
guidance doesn't actually require the
designated premises to be
on site at all times to authorize the
seller alcohol
what they should be is the delegated
powers
from the designated premises supervisor
authorizing his staff to act
on his behalf for the sound of alcohol
as it says under the guidance you can't
expect one person to be there
every minute of the day to authorize
every single cell of alcohol but they
should
be able to delegate the powers down to
their staff
is that help
is that clear counselor western i'll
answer your question thank you very much
right as we've just heard this is going
out of order
but um any part of anyone is now um
permitted to make a short closing
statement it will not
exceed two minutes the order of closing
statements will be
premises premises license holder
responsible authority
interested parties then applicant so
i will ask mr smith if he would like to
make a closing statement please
yes i'd just like to say that i
understand that we've had
problems but i think we've got
measures in place to resolve those
i'm working very closely with licensing
and plan in and
hope to have the opportunity to work
with
environmental health as well and i would
like
the opportunity to meet up with the um
the residents um perhaps on
and councillor wilkinson um
on a on a regular basis to discuss how
things are going
and i would like them
to contact me if there are any
any difficulties but um
yes i i think that that's about all i
have to say thank you
thank you responsible authority please
uh yes please um environmental health
ask the licensing subcommittee
to consider all options available to
them
and to consider if mr smith is a fit and
proper person
to be the dps or license holder to
crafty cars
to consider all the evidence presented
to you today
the broad scope and failings by mr smith
to run his business
in a safe and lawful manner to question
if it is appropriate to further
condition the premises
when all the evidence provided
demonstrates misdefiance and blatant
disregard for conditions
and rules already in place and that's
all i've got to say thank you
thank you very much interested parties
um
larissa uh i don't really have much to
say just obviously
just like for my statement i've made and
my written statement to be taken into
consideration with your decisions that
you make
thank you thank you very much unlikely
select not least but not last mr
uh mr wilkinson council wilkinson
chair sorry i don't know if you you've
missed ellie i'm not sure she wants to
say anything
she would have come in with the promises
license holder oh i beg your pardon
sorry okay fair enough
um yes i i'm going to keep mine very
very brief um
and i i think it's um i i echo
what siobhan sheridan has said and and i
think that
um it's important to recognize mr smith
as being the license holders not person
actually that's predominantly there
um and his son is a very different
person not that i've met him but what
i'm being told is very different person
to
to to mr john smith and the and the
people he surrounds himself with are as
well
um which i think is probably the reason
why nobody feels confident in
approaching the staff there and it's not
because of yourself mr smith there's
more
to the people that surrounding your son
um
but i i would urge the committee to
consider the fact that
as siobhan sheridan said that today we
are
12 months into the existence of the
crafty cask the only time it was ever
behaving itself
was a when covered locked it down march
and b
when uh covered started restricting it
again and the review came about
apart from that there's been all sorts
of problems and i accept
what mr smith is saying there's an
action plan in place but there is a huge
amount of resistance there
to comply with what the council is
saying it's more a case of well this is
what we want to do
um and and i think this needs to be
enforced if i'm honest with you
an action plan um is is
is not good enough it needs to be in
conditions so there's no doubt and i
totally
support what siobhan sheridan said the
reason for that is that it's enforceable
otherwise we're in no position to
enforce it if it's not done so
thank you thank you very much
sonia can i ask you that we come off
live stream now
and then we go and have uh steve greene
will
show us